hello everyone welcome back to the
channel for another interview an
interview for a show that i am deeply
obsessed with i have the showrunner of
human resources with me right now
kelly goluska hello oh my god
congratulations i don't know why i had
any doubt in my mind after seeing so
many seasons done so well with big mouth
but i don't know human resources just
like above and beyond exceeded my
expectations oh i'm so happy to hear
that i'm so glad that you like it and
that people are receiving it the way we
were hoping that they would it's very
very very smart i love both shows how
you let us have our fun but there's some
real insightful material in the mix
there
we tried it we probably put in some
vegetables with all the sweet stuff
very well done giving me a balanced meal
all right so to start here i wanted to
learn a little bit more about your
career path because you know in general
i feel like
producing in any capacity could mean a
million different things and for you
going through big mouth and hitting
human resources you've had so many
different titles a co-producer producer
supervising producer co-executive
producer i don't know if there's any
like normal like path to becoming a show
runner but why was that particular path
the right one for you
absolutely so i mean i started from the
bot the bottom quote unquote i was um i
started as an assistant on tv shows and
so i really just like
i i went i guess a more traditional path
than some people do and so i've just
worked on a bunch of shows i got my
first staff job and then
got lucky that bojack and big mouth both
went for so many seasons because i got
to grow in those shows and my level just
i kept rising the ranks as as you say um
so i i
as you get
to be a higher level and become a
producer level you have more
responsibilities but at the same time
you're still in the writers room
you know down on the ground writing
scripts with everybody else
with everyone else which is great so is
it fair to look at that list that i just
rattled off and think it's like like as
like a step up every single time or is
it like a step to the side and a
different type of role in any respect i
mean it depends on on which roles but
really it's kind of i've heard it
described this way so i will copy this
from whoever i got it from um but it's
sort of like ranks in the army so like
with each year you're on the show
generally especially if you do well you
raise in the ranks so your title changes
and you get more responsibility as you
go
all right well you have hit the
showrunner point and human resources is
very lucky to have you in that capacity
can we look back at day one of i guess
the inception of the idea can you tell
us what the biggest difference is
between what you pictured day one for
this show and what we wind up with in
the final product
oh that's a great question um i think i
think day one i mean we knew when we
started the writer's room that we were
doing episode one about birth and we
knew that we wanted or i i felt very
strongly i wanted to do death as well
because we're kind of showing the
breadth of human experience from the
moment you're born until the moment
you're gone you've got these creatures
helping you through life and
sort of like aiding you in this
difficult thing called humanity um so i
think the thing that i i don't know that
i didn't know that we would do is that
we could pack so much emotional punch
into these 10 episodes and the way that
we would kind of use our human stories
by you know starting with yara the
grandmother with alzheimer's and then
meeting different members of her family
and then just having that come together
that way we kind of
found the way that we would do the human
stories as we went and i feel very proud
of how we landed on that one everything
is very powerful episode nine just like
ruined me for a couple of hours like i
needed a minute to process and recollect
myself you're quite i mean
as a person who was has watched it a
million times because you ha you you go
through so many iterations i can't not
cry i mean i look at the pages of that
and i still cry it's really i mean it's
a testament to victor kinaj's writing of
that episode and our whole staff who
kind of gave
gave of themselves and their own
experience with this stuff and let us
use it you know
so incredibly well done all right let's
get into the monsters of it all in
particular can you tell me a little bit
about centering a show this time around
on the monsters versus the humans
because you know by focusing on human
characters you get this opportunity to
basically have you know guaranteed
layers and a whole bunch of different
influences in their lives but the
monsters are essentially supposed to
have tunnel vision so what was it like
upholding that but also making sure that
the monsters have meaningful arcs too
absolutely i mean for for our ship for
human resources it really the conception
of the idea which which really began
with the other big mouth creators mark
11 jennifer flackett nick kroll and
andrew goldberg was oh my god it was so
fun to go behind the scenes and go to
human resources where these creatures
work it would be so fun to do like a
workplace comedy with them so it started
with that and then we realized that in
doing that we could expand this universe
with the humans because the humans in
big mouth are all one age which is a
very potent age and a wonderful age to
explore because of
the like tumult that comes with being a
preteen and a teenager but being able to
do this with adults means we could
expand the number of emotions expand the
number of human you know experience
because there's such an age range that
we can deal with which was so fun and it
also allowed us to treat the creatures
as humans in a way because we had to
think beyond just the emotion that their
job is you know they're all sort of
well-rounded even if they start from a
place of horniness or love or logic did
you guys ever discuss pixar's inside out
it i just bring it up because i keep
comparing this i keep saying it's
basically the r rated version of inside
out and inside out has completely
changed the way that i process my own
emotions and now this show is kind of
doing it through these creatures 100 i
mean you can't you can't make this show
and not think about inside out because
inside out did such a beautiful job of
doing what we're doing it's just again
like that that movies you know span's
age range uh who it's for but this this
show is obviously not for kids um but it
was nice to kind of you know see how
well that was done and do our best to
expand upon it it's age-appropriate for
someone it's the best double feature
ever
um this is like kind of a personal
question so you could pass on this but i
keep obsessing over it i thought about
it with inside out now i keep thinking
about it uh with human resources but
have you given much thought to who your
primary creature is the one in your mind
that you know takes the lead and is the
more dominant force of the group yeah
totally and i i do think my my dominant
creature probably changes from time to
time but i think ultimately
i'm probably mostly love bug like i i
feel like i'm i'm
i was emmy and i'm like hoping to become
a sonia i'm somewhere in between them
right now i'm probably mostly love bug
with some ambition gremlin in there um
and definitely i have a shame wizard um
i grew up catholic i that guy's present
yeah i feel like this is gonna make me
sound like the most boring personal i'm
a person imaginable but i'm definitely
like a lot logic rock when i saw that
creature
i'm like oh
yeah that's that's a pretty strong force
in me right now
we've got some very solid logic rocks in
our room so don't don't knock it very
important
it makes me feel a lot better then of
all of the the newer monsters that we
get in in addition to the ones that you
introduced through big mouth which was
the toughest to crack or or which uh
which required the most you know
reshaping in order to get it to the
place you wanted it to be hmm
that is a great
question
um
i think grief keith from grief
while maybe not the hardest to crack he
ended up being
to me one of the more important ones to
to sort of come to the understanding and
again this is victor kinosh through and
through was a huge part of this the
understanding that grief
can be both scary and comforting was a
huge thing to come to to sort of get to
that thing where he can grow and grow
and grow and take over in a way that is
not okay until you give in to him and
then he cuddles you and he he makes you
feel better and he's there for you that
was a really
exciting thing to come to i would say
just like as you were saying that all i
could think was like how do you
accomplish that alongside a show with a
scene about boxing penises like i just
don't understand how you can have it all
i mean
we had luckily we had eight episodes
before that to help us with but it is i
mean when we were doing that episode
about claudia um and sonia and their
love affair and this like beautiful
thing beautiful tragic thing we were
like we're gonna need some some
something to cut the tension how about
somebody
did that particular storyline like make
you completely rethink the monster human
relationship not even just in human
resources and what you'll eventually do
in season two but also in big mouth too
because that really blows the doors wide
open to so many unique possibilities
totally and that's actually probably a
better answer for your previous question
that was really hard it was really hard
to like make sure that we were creating
this universe where we understood the
rules and we could we could help the
audience understand the rules where
suddenly this woman could see her and
she shouldn't um so that was very fun
and difficult to play with but i i think
we landed the plane i hope
all right so you just brought up a key
word for me it's rules i'm obsessed with
like show bibles and world building
rules so i don't know how much you've
really thought about this but
i guess have you ever kind of like
zoomed out in our respect because in the
convention episode you you show us that
there's different human resources for
different countries so is that the way
you envision this all being structured
that there's one per country or is it
broken down even further within that
it's broken down even further we have
talked about this a bit so like we
consider our human resources
office that we are in most of the time
the tri-state office so they're sort of
a region it's sort of like regional kind
of like the office show
regional offices all over the place and
we kind of did that for
our own understanding of like okay we
need to be able to contain this in some
way with our humans so that's that's how
we did it and that was a little bit
established in big mouth as well there
had been little hints about
working with specific areas
i know i think andrew's the long
islander i'm i'm a long islander as well
so being able to profit all this as it
takes place in that particular area of
the country always hits me nice and hard
right right
do you know what all of the side and
background monsters do because from you
know the very opening of the show when
it's explaining what human resources is
to i mean really any other scene the
convention everything do you know what
every single one is responsible for i
wish i could tell you i did but so many
of them are just the genius of our
artists creating these background
characters and and i will say that often
we in the writer's room get obsessed
with certain characters and then they
become we give them names we give them
jobs and we give them dialogue so
i have one specific question though for
one of them i don't know if you have an
answer to this there's a multi-headed
creature in episode nine that steps out
of the elevator like what what is that
what does it do
that is a gorgeous question i wish i had
an answer we we mostly one of the
writers came up with that bit that like
it seems like there's nine creatures
in the elevator and then you pan down
you see it's just one we should think
about
what a good job would be for a creature
with nine brains
there was a lot of them that caught my
eye along the way but that one in
particular
looking looking at big mouth now are
there any new creatures introduced in
human resources that we could see step
into the new season of big mouth that
haven't been part of it before
that's a great question and i i don't
know how much i'm allowed to answer for
that one but i think that they are
definitely looking especially because
they're you know they're doing that one
but i think that we're definitely
looking to now that this universe has
been expanded using some of those those
people that we had really a fun time
with in hr and bringing them over to big
mouth for sure
so many possibilities i love it i don't
know how much you'll be able to answer
these next two questions either but
obviously i've got to ask you a little
bit for uh some season two teases so
first is there anything that you didn't
have enough time to do on season one
that you're eager to start tapping into
in season two yeah i mean there's a
million there's a million things because
like this this
show allows this such a broad canvas
because it deals with all of human
experience so i think something that i
think about a lot in these last couple
of years is
like hope
like i i would like to dig into that
because it's something that i think we
all need so much of and can sometimes be
in short supply and i think it's an
interesting thing to think about um and
i think just digging into different
creatures point of views and sort of
featuring
featuring different people um
where we can uh is something that's
exciting to me as well
all right another another version of
that question now
what about in terms of i guess lessons
learned while you were making season one
are there any big takeaways from that
experience that we'll be able to see
influence how you present the material
in season two interesting um
i mean one one thing that it took us a
season to learn is
that these stories have to come from the
creature point of view first and
foremost because it's very easy
especially having written big mouth
already to think of them as coming from
the human perspective but the stars of
this show are the creatures so i think
we learned quickly that what they're
dealing with
is as important and then that is
reflected in the humans so we're kind of
like there are human avatars in a weird
way so that's something that i think
that we will deal with more as we go to
write season two i hope all right i'm
gonna close it out with one semi-weird
question inspired by inside out but in
your head canon
do animals have human resources
creatures in their brains yes 100 in my
head they do i mean my animal i thought
she was in here she's not i've got a big
dog who's like my number one child and i
tell her every morning and there's no
way she doesn't have creatures in there
she is she's as human as we are she just
can't
speak there's a spin-off episode idea in
there somewhere i need to see it so much
yes
makes me so greedy you guys have given
us so much so much already in a single
season kelly huge huge huge
congratulations and a thank you for this
show again i meant that inside out
comparison that movie was a big deal to
me when it came out and i just did not
imagine having so much fun with big
mouth and now human resources while also
actually taking some like really deep
ideas away from those shows to to have
and be able to process in my own
day-to-day so thank you and congrats
thank you so much i so appreciate it
you